ftpm continues with a good friend of the
program he's vikings tight end kyle
rudolph kyle what's going on man not
much mike thanks for having me on
well i appreciate talking to you and i'm
curious about a lot of things happening
with minnesota vikings as you may
imagine can you give me
one word
to describe this season so far
i think if i had to describe this season
one word it would be frustrating
and i would say frustrating because you
know when you when you look at the body
of work that we've had over the last six
weeks you know you sit here at one in
five
but you look at the fact that we played
three teams that were three of the last
undefeated teams uh we were in each of
those games lost two of them by one
point um
so you you are what your record says you
are that's that's the business we're in
it's about wins and losses
but at the same time i think we're much
better than a one in five football team
so you know thankfully for us we had the
opportunity over the bye week to
evaluate things that we've done well
and obviously there are things that
we're doing to cause us to lose football
games and we're able to address those uh
if we can eliminate those and continue
to do the things that we've done well
over the last month and a half uh you
know we got a chance to to win a few
football games and see where we're at
there's a saying in football that you
don't want to let one loss turn into two
how much do you think that the
disappointing loss in seattle hovered
over to the team to the point where it
impacted the ability
to win against the falcons the following
sunday oh no doubt i mean we've
struggled with that big time here over
the last few years whether it's um
emotional wins
i think back to the 2017 playoffs the
2019 playoffs
you win big games at the end and then
have a letdown the following week
then it's no different when you have an
emotional game and you're on the losing
side so you know like i said for us we
were able to kind of go back over the
bye week and
you know believe it or not you know for
us as an offense we found nine or ten
things that were in the top five of the
league in but then you know you go and
figure out okay well
why are we still one and five and you
look at our turnovers and our play in
the third quarter and you know we just
we can't put ourselves in those
situations and and beat teams week in
and week out
and i know it's useful to have that bye
week to have the opportunity to reflect
and reset but at the end of the day you
got to go back and play again you got
the packers coming up on sunday how does
having that opportunity to soul search
and self scout and reflect how does that
translate to a better product and more
wins the rest of the way
uh by eliminating the things that we
identified to cause us to lose football
games you know like i said you know a
lot of things you know the list was
certainly longer of things that we're
doing well
but at the end of the day
those two or three things that we
identified as causing us to lose
football games are what
are the glaring mistakes right now and
you know
the only way that that study that self
scout
is effective is if we go out and focus
on those issues and eliminate them
the
offense overall this year has seemed
different in ways although at times it
looks a lot like it did last year from
your perspective on the field running
the plays what's been the biggest
difference in the offense from last
season to this season
well i think you know
from a fundamental standpoint
the offenses from last year to this year
are very similar
but anytime you have a change in play
caller
you know the things that they like to
rely on the things that they like to get
to the rhythm that they get in as a play
caller is different and i think that's
the thing you see this year with gary
collin plays as opposed to kevin
the fact that you don't have fans at one
of the loudest stadiums which creates
one of the best home field advantages in
the nfl how much of a distraction or an
issue is that just the fact that it's a
crazy upside down
season in a crazy upside down world do
you think that's crept in at all and
affected the performance of the team
well i mean first of all i have to say
that we're extremely fortunate to be
even out there on sundays and and
playing so uh you know you got to kind
of look at it from that perspective but
at the same time you know i can go back
to week one the last time we played
these guys
and i think aaron got us on hard counts
three times and you know in a normal
year with fans
we might get them with three false
starts and then there's certainly no way
he can use a hard count in u.s bank
stadium so um you know i think that's
been one of the advantages that we've
had and lost not having fans in the in
the crowd this year uh but at the same
time it's it's that way everywhere it's
not like there's a stadium or two that's
at capacity and they have this great
home field advantage uh you know we've
played in seattle with no fans we've
played in indy with very little fans
houston with very little fans so it's
kind of just the nature of every stadium
in the nfl right now
now look i know your goal at this point
is to turn it around and win games and
pull back into the playoff conversation
especially since there's seven spots
this season in the nfc but i know that
from the league's perspective there's a
huge concern kyle about teams when they
fall out of contention the players maybe
not being as careful about keeping the
virus out of the facility keeping
themselves on the right side how much of
it is a concern for you that if the
vikings don't turn it around and you get
to the point where the last four or five
games don't count per se that that maybe
guys aren't going to be as careful as
they've been all year well i think the
biggest thing and you know our guys
realize this and i certainly hope that
guys across the league realize that that
um you know if you don't play you're not
getting paid so uh no matter if you're
2 and 12 or 12 and 2 at the end of the
year and
you know if you get
lacks on these protocols that the nfl
and the nflpa have put in place and you
know you caused an outbreak on your team
you know at that point we're out of five
weeks to move games around and you know
it'll be hard to reschedule games so
if we don't play you're not going to get
your paychecks so
hopefully that's enough motivation
throughout the locker rooms across the
league
to make sure that we get this finished
i know it happened during the bye week
so it wasn't a normal practice week
where guys would be together like they
normally are but the yannick and gawkway
trade what kind of shock wave did that
send through the roster well i think the
biggest thing and you know i'm in a
different situation than most of the
guys are here being that i've been here
for 10 years and uh you know have a feel
for our front office and the decisions
that they make and
you know i've learned over the last 10
years the to trust their decisions and
know that they always have uh this team
and this organization's best interest in
mind and you know when you look at it
and you look at the future of this
organization um you know our salary cap
problems going forward knowing that we
probably won't be able to keep him here
next year and you get an extra draft
pick out of it to help make this team
better next year so you know i always
have the
the utmost respect and faith in our
front office to make tough decisions
like that now anytime something like
this happens the obvious reaction from
the outside is who's next and i've seen
the name kyle rudolph mentioned by some
in the media as a guy who could be next
what what kind of anxiety level do you
have that you're going to get a phone
call from someone with the team telling
you that between now and tuesday at four
o'clock central time you're gonna be
finishing the season and your career
elsewhere
uh well you know i joked around a couple
of times this week that i feel like i've
been on the trade block for the last
three years and i'm still here in
minnesota so
uh you know i i love it here i hope to
finish my career here but you know as
you know when you're around this
business long enough it is a business
and people have to make decisions so you
know i can't control that uh all that i
can control is going out to practice and
and doing everything i can to prepare
myself to go play well against the green
bay packers has anyone given you an
indication that you're you're safe that
it's not going to happen this year uh
like i said i haven't heard anything uh
you know i joked about being on the
trade block for the last three years and
and i found myself on a few other teams
a couple different times uh in reality
i'm still here so i don't see anything i
know the folks in minnesota are glad
you're still there and they hope you
stay there for the rest of your career
and beyond tell us about this auction
that you currently have going on there
there are some fascinating items there's
one in particular that i think plenty of
people would love to get behind the
wheel of kyle yeah we so i had a polaris
slingshot and it's an incredibly fun
three-wheel vehicle and um
it was funny because i got a different
polaris i got a ranger which is a little
more practical than a two-seat kind of
motorcycle vehicle
and
like most decisions in your life when
you when you buy a new toy and there's
not room in the garage uh the wife comes
in and says all right you need to get
rid of the old one uh you know awesome
so what are we gonna do with the
slingshot and
um
with our involvement at the university
of minnesota masonic children's hospital
we haven't been able to do
a lot of the events that we are
accustomed to doing on a normal year
so we thought this was a great way to
raise a little bit of money for the
hospital
and try to help everyone that's at the
hospital that we would normally help
with a lot of events throughout the year
yeah and that's available to bid on tell
us where we can bid on and what other
items are available so if if you go on
either of my social media pages twitter
instagram
there's a link that has the auction on
it and you know obviously we understand
i think the slingshot is up over twenty
thousand dollars right now and you know
not everyone has twenty thousand dollars
to donate for a slingshot so there are
other items um you know a pair of my
cosmic cleats uh from a few years back
that were for the children's hospital
and then a signed helmet as well so
there are other auction items that you
can go on in an auction and there's
actually even a last part that just is a
straight donation to the hospital so
just trying to do our best to raise some
money for the hospital during difficult
times
well kyle i'll tell you this i've got a
nephew who is extremely generous with
his uncle's money
and he actually sent me a link
to the slingshot auction before he even
knew that i was going to be talking to
you so he's trying to get me to bid on
but the problem is i'd be in the same
situation you are i've got a polaris
ranger i'd have to get rid of that to
fit the slingshot in the garage so then
i could auction that off and just i
guess it would just continue
indefinitely
it's it's great what you're doing kyle
and we will give the auction plenty of
publicity at profootballtalk.com we wish
you all the best and here's to a victory
on sunday and many more for the vikings
the rest of the year thanks for some of
your time thanks mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports